here's the problem you know is that um
when you're it's not so much sales but
brainwashing that was going on and when
you're brainwashing people or trying to
create a certain culture or a thought
culture right
there's this side to it it's number one
the constant reinforcement of one
message it's a constant reinforcement
but barning a message danger danger you
know death death death you stay home say
you know stop every world is changing
but there's another side to it too you
have to squash all other competing
messages and that's where the platforms
came in and they literally stopped free
speech and they made it so you could
only hear one message that brainwashed
people
all right people our first live in
studio in house what are we calling this
shoot
with the original wolf of wall street
jordan belfort what's up my friend who
also fled los angeles
and we are here living the life in miami
florida you look like miami except you
got the black shirt so that's a little
la but the tan you look like a million
bucks you just told me you're 59 years
old
okay
what's going on but it's an interesting
type of fleeing you know we come from
long island yeah and they fled from like
the bronx out to long island this is
like a fling back with the cross country
fleeing you know fleeing i don't know
what is a combination of taxes bad
government
crime due to prosecutors not
you know arrested for petty that's like
i don't know alex you're in new york
right i remember when i cried it was so
bad when i grew up that you went to
times square you would just never come
home you were gonna get a good chance
you were getting killed right drugs and
sex shops that it was a time when they
death wished
right yes and then some guy named rudy
giuliani came in you could hate him or
love the guy but what he did was he just
had this zero tolerance policy on
lifestyle crimes squeegee people
arrested any petty got arrested and you
know what happened it trickled up yeah
and murder rate plummeted violent crime
plummet it was really interesting police
presence sword
so gee what a shock defund the police
and look what happens and now they're
literally doing the reverse where the
petty crimes are the ones they're
letting you off on jump the turn style
you're good to go that's steal some
stuff out of cvs you're good to go
that's the root of like
it's i saw it i'll never forget it cause
like it was like oh that's so terrible
he's addressed in the squeegee this run
and you watched it just cleaned up and
miraculously cleaned up the city it was
amazing you know so when i called you i
think like second week in december or i
texted you just to say hey i moved to
miami and then you respond a minute
later you're like i moved to miami i had
no idea you were moving you didn't know
why i was moving i got out real quick i
was just like i got to get out of here
how long did it take you to figure out
that cali just wasn't working or la
wasn't working we had talked about a
little bit about a year ago but where
you lived i was a little more off the
beaten path in the valley you lived in a
super nice area in the hills but sort of
right below that a friend of mine
who owns a huge fashion over rich
fashioned over he was about maybe a
quarter mile from me
he got followed home in the hills there
and there was a shootout they shot his
bodyguard and his bodyguard killed one
of the people i mean like and this has
happened like once i don't know how i
don't exaggerate but it's happening
frequently yeah i was hearing gunshots
in encino that it's just like you know
you just can't wear a watch i mean it's
like you're my wife's from argentina
she's like when you go to buenos aires
don't wear a watch it's like oh yeah la2
now
was that it for you i mean were there a
couple things like the taxes obviously
you're a money guy we'll talk about some
of that kind of stuff like
you love success like that's your whole
thing you you like love that more than
anybody was that driving you nuts or
were you willing to everyone in vegas
for a while you know again i don't i
don't mind paying taxes but i do minds
if they're not using the money wisely
they're wasting the money that kind of
bothers me they're using it for things i
don't agree with um but
just to me it was a combination of
number one when trump changed the law
that didn't allow you to write off your
state taxes against your federal that
was a that was a big hit for someone
like myself and a lot of people that was
one thing i didn't agree with that but
hey you know whatever
you know can't agree with everyone
something you know what policies right
um
but it was a combination of of the taxes
the lifestyle and also the politics like
you know listen you know i'm like
probably very much conservative fiscally
socially liberal as you can get that's
me basically in a nutshell but i felt
like
that like it was almost this weird
virtue signaling how low can you go on
the virtue signaling con sibling
continuum and just like it's
uncomfortable i want to live amongst
that stuff and and then when covert hit
it was like i came down the floor and it
was like free at last free like
right were you shocked like eve every
day that i've been here i'm like man i
can't believe it i feel like i'm waking
up in a dream every day
i'm going to tell you i i got in some
trouble on on on the
instagram and uh youtube i got my stuff
taken down for saying that what do you
do lockdowns don't work
but they what do you what are you
anti-science i know right but it's like
particular like i was saying things like
it's my opinion i'm like i think that
you're locking down the wrong people i
think we should lock down older people
who are who really would get affected
and let the people who were healthy go
out and work and all the money that
we're gonna save we can take the opioid
caviar and flavor your champagne the
rest of their lives you know i'm saying
take care of the older people but
protect them instead of just locking
everyone down causing economic chaos and
it didn't work anyway you know the
greatest thing honestly was omicron the
last one because it was so infectious
that everyone just got it so it was
natural herd immunity and that was
really i think what ended this pen never
moved that anything else was omicron was
so contagious i was in the last day of
uruguay for uh new year's i think the
whole everybody in the whole island that
you know whole area items it was just
that's how contagion was and you know
but people weren't really dying from it
and it was i think you know at least i
think the best end you could have had to
hopefully you know it's the end but to
what was just to me he almost like uh
how did i say it was almost like a
cascade like a series of of of actions
by world governments to do i'm not sure
even what they were trying to do
but do you think it's over like to me
act two is coming falsies just dying
he's like just yeah you can't wait he's
praying that you know like listen i i
think that um
you never know
the difference with with covid
and in the beginning listen it could
have been the spanish flu
but it wasn't yeah and they i don't know
why they couldn't accept that like like
it wasn't the spanish flu like the
spanish was a very different thing when
people were just like literally in the
ui in the prime just dropped that just
like that and that was it was very
different this was you know something
that was in a different level but it was
almost like there was like this weird
um a global
i don't know if it's a conspiracy it's
like it's almost like this it's like the
madness is contagious almost like this
the mass delusion that was happening and
i just still don't know why i mean i
really don't understand it because it
never made sense to me like why
okay i get it it's it's a real virus
people are getting sick right some
people are very very susceptible but
like when you looked at it largely which
wasn't making any sense like loved ones
being locked down and they're i don't
know the counter on the screen i mean
like what the [ __ ] i mean like
you don't strike me as the type that
would lock down very well like you need
you need people right like you really
need people i i was
my wife
she was ready to kill me because like
she's like she's you know she's more
buying citizen like you know she's
listening to the news you know her
english wasn't perfect back in that so
she's like oh she's deaf that that's
locked down lock that right you know and
i'm like people coming over hugging them
she's like what are you doing she's like
i'm like listen you're gonna kill me
from disinfectant she's disinfecting the
food it's coming spraying the freaking
things with [ __ ] like ammonia i'm
like i'm gonna die of ammonia poisoning
okay not from kobe right so she was
really careful and i was just not i
literally went out and i said you know
what [ __ ] it i'd rather just get it i
wanted to get it because i wanted to
become immune to it and that's what
happened by the way as i got it and i
was sick for a couple of days and i'm a
very strong immune system and i got sick
i have not nothing that would ever give
me a predecessor like i'm just saying
nothing i feel strong heart i'm i'm not
i'm not overweight i'm not the right
blood type so it was like hey you know
let me get it i got it i was sick for a
couple of days nothing bad then i got it
a second time i only tested positive and
those symptoms and then since then i've
literally walked into like overboards
and i can't catch it anymore right you
know i mean
not that i want to give these freaks any
ideas but when they bring kovid back i
just know they're bringing it back did
they screw up something in the sales job
because after the two weeks to flatten
the curb thing i kind of realized it was
all nonsense i knew the old world wasn't
coming back i didn't believe them i
didn't believe the body language the
messaging the commercials everything
based on fear i mean should they have
done something different sale what
should we watch out for i guess is what
i'm asking you this is the problem you
know is that um
when you it's not so much sales but
brainwashing that was going on and when
you're brainwashing people or trying to
create a certain culture or a thought
culture right
there's this side to it it's number one
the constant reinforcement of one
message it's a constant reinforcement
but barning a message danger danger you
know death death death
you stay home say you know stop every
world is changing but there's another
side to it too you have to squash all
other competing messages and that's
where the platforms came in and they
literally stopped free speech and they
made it so you could only hear one
message that brainwashed people but even
that i think it was p you know listen
there was many people like almost had no
choice i mean like the society just
literally you know they they virtue
signal loss to like to be rational
people to death but like it was like
are you like
you actually believe this [ __ ] like it
was it was ridiculous like you know you
know am i gonna believe my eyes or the
nonsense i'm hearing in the in the
present by the way it's still going on
right now with other things i've
literally it just shocks me
like the lack of legitimacy
on tv with the news it's just it's like
what do we do
there's more than one side to the story
for sure yeah and and that's awful it
doesn't mean like that it's that he
shouldn't be you know um you know
thought of as you know as a bad guy for
invading a country but it's just like i
don't know like you know oh so you're a
putin apology yeah exactly
yeah you said something with nuance what
are you nuts but i saw a really
interesting interview with on tucker and
i knew that before like i've been
thinking this all along and i didn't say
it this time you know why because it is
a very difficult
type rope to walk
because it's not my responsibility i'm
not that guy like i'm that's not who i
am you know i'm not here to bring the
news to the world
but if i was i certainly would speak my
mind more but people are dying it's
awful it's [ __ ] awful what's going on
there right but that being said it is
not black and white and this guy's
linsky is no freaking um you know he's
no um just a you know stellar you know
person that represents democracy and he
just banned 11 political parties lefty
political parties why but why in the
name of democracy why isn't the news
talking about this i think because they
want to do it here too and they're just
running the test the test game i mean i
know that all sounds nuts but well
that's a good one is there anything that
i could say or anything that you would
hear that you'd be like nah that can't
be right like that everything is so out
of whack right now
that it's like you believe anything it
seems pretty obvious this is the
military-industrial complex doing what
they do best
war
weapons destruction
um like this guy zelinski is saying
we're on the verge of world war iii over
ukraine yeah why
it's like not even a strategic point for
us like why is ukraine what about what's
going on in syria or yemen like this all
these other slaughters around the world
yeah or we did to iraq or afghanistan
like like why is this suddenly why are
we supposed to go to war and start world
war three
over ukraine as bad as i think what's
happening in ukraine i'm not saying it's
not terrible and i'm sympathetic to the
people and i've been to ukraine many
times now amazing people but
like you know i
i'm not interested in starting world war
iii over this what do you make of how
they changed the messaging so quickly so
like the state of the union it's like
biden does a half hour on ukraine to
start as he's standing in there with no
masks pelosi behind him she's 900 he's
800 and that the average american is not
walking around thinking about ukraine
that often and again that's not
diminishing what's going on there and
you can't just invade a sovereign nation
but like
how do they the messaging of how they
flip it right they flip it so quickly
and get everybody's eye on something
else it's shocking it's it's it's really
shocking
and i think that the most shocking part
is probably always like this it's just
that we live in a world now where it's
very hard to not have things be
transparent the manipulation was always
there we always
along for the days of walter crock he
was probably just as bad you know it's
like so i just think that right now it's
like really hard to hide anything so you
have these sort of you know more
discerning minds that are just saying
[ __ ] they call [ __ ] and i think
those minds were out there before but
they had nowhere to call [ __ ] so you
have social media about the platforms
where people could have voices so the
dissenting at least gets out there
somewhat before it's squashed it's it's
so funny because we've done each other's
shows a bunch of times before whenever
when i've had you go over for dinner or
whatever it's like we can do the
politics thing and it's funny to me that
you sort of talk about politics but you
could if you never talked about politics
again you'd be fine i don't know
i don't listen i'm very much into
politics
but it's not where i you know my
heartbeat is not in politics i i
intrigues me
in the sense that you know it's the most
corrupt um
shockingly corrupt you know institution
and
[Music]
what's happened is is that the press and
the attack squads have created a
paradigm where no one that really has
anything good going to want to run it
for office like trump i couldn't believe
he did it like i mean i don't maybe he
didn't realize what he was getting
himself into but like why would you run
for office like it's just the most evil
thing that it's like they dig up any
dirt that you have it just try it's all
about undermining you tripping you up
discrediting you it's it's shocking it's
like almost like the gestapo is on both
sides just trying to destroy destroy
propaganda and it's not about truth and
it's not about making the country a
better place i really think that the u.s
has seen its better days and and ain't
coming back i don't think so so so do
you see any way out of this like to me i
see that there will be pockets out where
we are right now miami is the future
florida is the future i think there's
there's like a base there and all the
people moving and they get it why
they're moving here texts moving here i
think there's a there's a bullish
attitude here but i think a lot of it is
gone do you think do you think it's gone
all together or it's just gonna
what happens is
rich people
people that not just the rich rich but
just people not to make money they're
always going to make money and they're
always going to live good lives they're
survivors people that are going to be
really poor are always going to be dirt
poor because they just have a dirt poor
mentality they they don't want to do
anything to get themselves out of
poverty but then there's all these other
people that really work hard in the
middle class
those are the ones that are getting
squeezed the most those people are
having the american jeep romp from them
so like to me it doesn't matter to me at
all it doesn't matter you're always
going to make a lot of money you're
you're at that point where you oh you
make a little bit more this doesn't
matter you get the life you want but i
think what happens is it's the people in
the middle
that really really suffer and you know
the dollar
buys less and less
job opportunities becoming you know
scarcer and scarcer and this woke-ism i
think is the death of of so much
liberty in this country and it's like i
look at this this class means the
picture of that of the swimmer
it says it all you look at her she's
seven feet tall and the little girls are
cowering and like in and people just
don't stop that like the country has
lost its moral compass she has a penis
by the way
she does she has a penis she has a still
yeah she's still got the penis so the
girls in the locker room are not happy
because she walks around and she's got a
penis really and we're saying she right
because you're trying to be respectful
at some level it's like a rudder maybe
if when she swims
that's funny uh but like something you
know what i mean it's like you're trying
to be respectful i i know you you are
right so you're using them but you're
also mocking the reality of we this is a
big dude who in effect is crushing these
girls and and the feminist terrible
here's the thing though like you want
your daughter around that age right what
i call a she
don't if she wants to be cold she how
cool is she it doesn't
it doesn't bother me i don't care yeah
like if cecil says you want to be called
she or or a big fat glute i'll call you
that too i don't care what you want to
be called like i don't care about labels
like that so that makes her happy that
makes her happy i guess some people will
say no she's a he and and i won't refuse
to i don't care like i'm sympathetic i
don't want her to be as happy as she can
or whatever you want to call or write it
but now it's at the expense
this is just nonsense it's [ __ ] pure
nonsense
and if you don't know that
you're sick you're crazy like if you
don't know that that's patently unfair
it's beyond obvious it's
it's patently ridiculous
how could this be allowed do you think
anyone really buys it or they're just
all in on the mob and they're all in on
the group thing anyone that buys that is
[ __ ] brain dead no they're brain it's
literally it's part of something much
darker and more evil to have that woman
or man whatever you want to say she is
all right competing against women that
have worked like their whole lives to
get to this spot and like one girl
didn't make the cut that's just it's
[ __ ] up yeah and there's no way it's
it's just not there i said this by the
way i came out and said this on
tick-tock a long time ago right when it
first started i came out and by the way
i was genuinely support i was generally
supportive it was very i got no hate on
the only hate i think i got was from
from um from people conservative people
because i said listen i'm i'm socially
liberal i start saying i'm very liberal
but
i mean this is not about that this is
about just fairness and this is just
it's idiotic and uh i don't know why she
would or he would want what it's an
empty victory right wait so what were
the conservatives getting on you for for
like how could you say you're socially
liberal oh
got it
because i am i mean i want you who's
[ __ ] who what why care really give a
[ __ ] like who [ __ ] who and what like i
mean honestly i don't care about that
stuff i said i'm prejudiced against two
types of people lazy people and stupid
people everyone else
i'm okay with you know yeah i want to
back up to say you said before about the
government because it was it was making
me think of wolf of wall street so the
thing about the movie i mean the movie's
so freaking brilliant i won't make you
talk about it because you've talked
about it a bajillion times
but you know you base you're the hero of
the movie obviously and yet you're also
doing some illegal [ __ ] you're doing
some moral [ __ ] or however you want to
describe it
but you hate the feds more you hate the
people going after you more and they're
supposed to be the good guys in this
right because you're doing stuff with
the penny stocks or whatever it is
and that i think sort of captures what
you said about the government before
like they've done so much stuff now that
it's sort of like the sopranos you're
never rooting against tony he's killing
people and you're still rooting for him
does that tell you something about how
backwards everything is in an odd way oh
i think that the lines
of right and wrong morality have been
very much blurred i think people just
realize for example it's just my case
specifically like people know that like
what i did
was nothing compared to they did a
goldman sachs and merrill lynch and
these guys bankrupted iceland and greece
it almost took down the entire world
economy
and and no one went to jail like at
least i went to jail for a couple of
years and did my time and like i had to
pay the price i had to rebuild my life
like that was like a thousand times
worse doesn't mean that riding was right
but but people also saw like there's
like this sort of you know i think
people like the almost the tortured soul
type like like i'm like you're watching
me walk off the edge why you stopped
like you know so
you see there was goodness in me there
was misguidedness in me and and i think
people like that complexity and you can
root for someone who i think you feel
like genuinely they're almost their own
worst enemy they're not killing people
and even by the way with tony robles
tony you can root for tony too but like
in this case i'm not killing people but
you're saying why why and i think people
can see themselves
in a lot of the of the characters in
that type of movie and that's scorsese's
brilliance
like he doesn't moralize he just puts
characters up that are actually real and
complex and you're watching good people
do bad things in bed and and people that
are you know all terrible will do good
things when you look back on all that
like are you just like even when you
post pictures a lot of times on
instagram you'll post pictures of of
what you were doing back then you know
30 years ago like what you were actually
doing like are you like man that was
just freaking great even though how long
were you in jail for 22 months
so all right
little more than jesse but yeah
you know one thing i'll say is that
when i look back at what happened the
one thing i wish i did less of was the
drugs yeah the drugs did not enhance
things they
corrupted a lot of things and they made
a lot of memories like really
far less enjoyable and colorful than
they should have been for example i've
fallen asleep in the finest restaurants
in the world
i got booked for a speech in the next
month in monaco right and they got a
beautiful suite at the hotel de paris
right and i was like oh yeah i fell
asleep at the louis fourteenth
restaurant in the bowl of soup and they
you know it's twelve thousand dollar
dinner i can't remember it but i
remember with all bread and i thought my
wife had to pick my head up out of the
frickin soup right so like that was like
the story of my life so that aspect i
look back and say i wish i could have
you know done things differently with
the drugs um but other than that you
know when i look at it you know i
wouldn't change anything because it was
my it was like what got me to this point
in my life obviously i made some
mistakes i had a lot of fun did a lot of
things right as well
uh but i think looking back at your life
and trying to say i shouldn't have done
that i don't think it's healthy what do
you think
kept you going like that you're not
broken now like you're so thriving it's
every time i'm around you and everyone
knows it like you're infectious with
your energy this is exactly who you are
off the camera like you just freaking
love life like what how did you ever get
to a point where you were like starting
to break or anything like that yeah of
course i did i mean i think that you
know um the worst part was before i went
to jail it's like you're dying in slow
motion and that's like where you know
you can't because you know you're going
you can't restart your life and you know
just like you know it's like it was like
i lived in the big house still then
taking this like roam fly the falling
empire of rome like if you're watching
the house collapse or everything
collapse around me right
um
you know for me
the amount of pride that i took in
rebuilding my life ethically i can't
tell you like what that meant to me to
go out and prove to myself to my
children
that was really not the world to my
children that that like that i would
just go out right again and just do
things so straight as an arrow and
empower people all over the world and
make even more money and like to me that
was like and that just like was like
something that just kept me going in the
early days and it just snowballed and
fed in itself and fed in itself and um
yeah my life today is far better than it
ever was back in the craziest times of
strand yeah that's got to be a crazy
retraining right to try to do things
fully on the up and up we were going to
try to do something and i have a feeling
we'll do something in the future but
even when we were in a little
negotiations and then things just moved
too fast you were basically like just
give me something and i'll make it work
like you didn't want to negotiate you
were just like let's make it nice and
easy and then things just happen right
so move along in a different way but
like
was that a real shift for you like how
you're going to do business like
actually how you're going to engage in
that
so
yes and no i think one of the lessons i
learned was that
if you're a really good negotiator right
and you negotiate a deal where it's so
great for you and badly other people
that's not a good negotiation it just
ends up in a lawsuit aka steve madden's
shoes like when steve came to me he was
very young he was naive and i took his
company from him legally and i took 85
because he didn't know better and all i
did was created animosity down the road
so i don't think a great negotiation is
when you
get such a good deal that you [ __ ]
everyone else over and also just like i
just just refuse to cut corners like in
my life my value system right now is
just simply it's just it's just based on
creating value people so i there's a
reason why i haven't that is why you
launch any nfts yet there's a reason why
i haven't launched an empties because
i'm not sure if the market is ready and
i don't know i'll make a quick 10
million yeah but probably people who buy
them might lose a quick 7 million so i
didn't do it i just did
i would love to have the extra money but
i have enough money i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna engage in transactions or any
business practices that i'm not giving
more value than i receive and frankly
i've ended up making more money because
of that it's my greed shows me if i'm
greedy that means do that give people
more value because you make more in the
long run when you see these insane
policies of just printing money and then
biden comes out oh it has inflation has
nothing to do with printing money and
it's not our fault
like like as a guy who understands
business
you want to punch the screen or what
yeah so mine's an idiot i mean yeah and
i think everyone knows that he's not
he's not even the piece of puppet yeah i
mean it's like it's like the movie's so
bad like it's like dave we're like let's
[ __ ] great movie where can we find
someone so stupid and so malleable and
just so much of a puppet like here we go
right to be clear you're not talking
about me david there was a movie dave
with uh
kevin thank you right okay yeah great
movie by the way yeah
so
biden
is a total puppet
and everyone everyone knows this you're
not making any decisions right
and um
he says stuff that's
it's idiotic
it's just it's just it's like patently
false and anyone knows the first thing
about money and economics and the way
the world works well it's like it's just
like it's just silliness and i'm not
quite sure why he says that i would
think that people would coach him better
um
do you think they they actually like
i've come to the position that i believe
they fundamentally want to i've said
this they either want to fundamentally
destroy the country or alter it in a way
that nothing that we've known about
america will exist anymore and and the
dream that eventually got our parents to
be you know middle class in long island
and we grew up basically in the same
exact spot a couple years difference
like that dream of then us doing better
is they want to destroy that because
they want us as cogs in the system i'll
tell you a a little analogy here so my
wife's argentinian right and the country
was destroyed by socialists by the
perons
the terrorists right
and um
and they're called paranistas if you're
you know the parties paradises right my
wife's family is wealthy and all those
people are anti-parrotista right
and i know there's one of them of the
group it's mostly wealthy people they're
all on the right there's one guy who's
apparentista he's loaded
he makes money from the government oh
you don't say
his gig you get it yeah he's a perennial
he's making all his money by budget and
just stealing basically through you know
unions and stuff like that it's just the
biggest hustle ever like this is the
hustle so like you know they want that
because it's just it's living people in
power
there's so much wrong with our system
right now and like starting with term
limits and professional politicians like
these are all things that are just
destroying in the country from the
inside like a rot and there's just like
and it's like how could they like they
pass this thing everyone has to get a
covenant injection but congress
like how it like
i don't understand like like they it's
like they also gave themselves a raise
and they're doing a hell of a job but
getting back to your point with like you
know with things he says about you know
money and printing money and i'm like
it's just the fact that when you print
money it leads to inflation and the
worst part is the one thing that we have
going for us over the last
50 years since the 70s when nixon cut a
deal with saudi arabia stabilizing the
dollar as the global reserve currency
oil would only be done in dollars in
exchange for security guarantees to
saudi arabia right that set the dollar
firmly as the global reserve currency
the petro dollar right
they're
going to china now and pricing contracts
in one
and by cutting off russia from the
banking system i think it was the
stupidest thing in the world all you're
doing is you're hasting the move away
from the dollar as the global reserve
currency and once that's done
all bets are off because we cannot print
money
if we're not the reserve currency
without having runaway hyper inflation
that's how we get away with it because
with a global reserve currency so the
rules don't apply to us if other
countries try to print money like that
then the world bank comes in ah you're
scam they shut the country down they you
know they it goes into hyperinflation
they call on their loans and we don't do
that because we're a global reserve
currency that's gonna and i think it's
ending very quick and hastening because
of the move with russia it was a huge
error is
is the biggest issue that nobody really
understands this
like that nobody really gets
i think people understand it well i
guess a certain set of people do but
that not enough of just the average
person they here buy it and say oh we're
printing more money and they're like oh
well i guess there's more money
i think that there's a couple of things
right number one yes a lot of people
don't understand it but something else
the left
is really really good
at using emotionally charged issues to
hijack the narrative
so what they do for example is like okay
from a fiscal perspective
cutting russia off from the dollar and
so is the dumbest thing ever because it
hastens it forces them to go into china
it forces them away from dollars and it
serves our long-term cause to have the
world using dollars
but the moral justification is get them
off and that's the most important thing
is the moral part so the left is always
on the sort of moral high ground that
it's like and and i said this before in
our last interview like that the ends
justifies the means and i'll tell you if
you go back in history any time
countries or or societies were operating
under that paradigm of the ends
justifies means bad [ __ ] happened
and bad [ __ ] happens when the ends
justify the means it ends badly almost
every single time well nothing's off the
table right because if it's just about
the ends you'll do anything
you're going to end up killing an awful
lot of people putting off a lot of
people into poverty
tell me how
you can literally
take a country on purpose from energy
independence and make it dependent on
foreign energy like it's like what it's
like it's like why because of global
warming because you know that's the most
important thing so again they hijack the
narrative that's really what's happening
is they use these things like it's just
like morally it's like this is the moral
high ground and i i think the us is like
no moral lying around on anything like
it's like a joke you know and it's so
sad that i'm actually reading al jazeera
now
like i use al jazeera yeah and bbc i
hate to tell you about this and fox i
try i have to read all of them trying to
find what's can i get some truth out of
here yeah i'm reading everything i can
get my hands on to trying to say will
someone say something different than
everybody else you know it's scary
i hate to tell you about the government
of qatar is probably not giving you the
truth either but i get i get your point
i want that opportunity i want to i want
to read tasks for example i want to say
tesla's thing like what's the other side
i was out for dinner with the ukrainian
uh right when the invasion started
and i'm like all this stuff of
nazification is ridiculous he goes it's
actually true
he goes no that actually is nazis and
and he is so against putin haiti putin
he was devastated he lost his business
because well that part though is
actually true so the fact is thing is
not nazis and there's a whole big nazi
issue and there is a nazi party like
literal not literally yeah people can't
believe it because we've so ruined the
word yeah they literally are there
there's a problem with it there and it's
true and the fact that we're denying
that
why would we deny it okay putin could
still be an [ __ ] and that could be
true like it's more complex nuance right
yeah i mean he still has no right to
invade a sovereign country but there are
nazis there and it is an issue
so the nazis are the good guys now
that's how stupid they've made everybody
my enemy yeah yeah i want to ask you
about uh fu money because you hear a lot
of people say this you know once you get
fu money you can do whatever you want
and i would say with ver you know i know
a lot of people now that are are very
wealthy some with the b in front of it
some with billions and i would say with
the exception of peter thiel who
actually puts his money where his mouth
is and says unpopular things i know a
lot of rich people that are that are
more afraid i think than the average
person because you suddenly start
feeling you have more to lose
what do you think about that so
i think there's different categories of
people
there's people who
are
worth over a certain amount where they
have [ __ ] you money whether that's a
billion or 100 million whatever that
means they have enough money but their
businesses
are
susceptible to public shaming
so they have to be careful because they
have a fiduciary responsibility they can
be cancelled by the left so they have to
play the game and inside they're
probably saying this is a bunch of [ __ ]
and ridiculous nonsense right but they
actually are playing the game that they
have to play because they might be rich
but they also have responsibilities to
shareholds and stuff so that's
understandable because they just have to
do that or else they'll have huge issues
like disney i think this guy from disney
really thinks that teaching
three-year-olds and five-year-olds about
um transgenderism is a good thing who
could think that who could possibly
think that's a good thing i dig in his
own grave and he doesn't even realize it
or maybe he does realize it do you think
he maybe does realize that he's given it
to the mob and you know it's just it's i
don't understand i don't you know you
know listen you're you're gay right and
you know it's just shocking
you're [ __ ] you're lucky because i
wish i was gay because i like guys i'm
just not gay i get along really well
with guys that'd be a gift i think it's
a gift
if i could pass it on i know you'd pass
it on right but but here's the thing
it's very i have this theory okay so let
me unpack if you'll be here right i am
but a humble listener
gays was so
terribly persecuted
terrible [ __ ] happened to gay people it
was so [ __ ] up in in england the
united states was like people would go
to jail yeah people were like he was
going committed for being correct so
there was a real [ __ ] problem with
gay people and a lot of people are gay i
think a lot i think it's a much larger
portion of the population is bisexual or
hassles i think it's a very substantial
amount of people it's [ __ ] up that
that had [ __ ] had to change it had to
change like it and and hollywood which
has a large percentage probably higher
than the average right for whatever
reason because it's arts or whatever
right and some very powerful like the
geffens of the world they they did [ __ ]
they had to do they it was good and it
was good it had to change
but wait what do you mean by it
in other words the gays were persecuted
you couldn't come out of the closet and
you i mean it's just it was [ __ ] up to
be gay yeah and it's
i mean it's disgusting okay i think it's
unfair and i think people should be able
to be happy it just doesn't make sense
to me it doesn't make i couldn't imagine
not being able to love the person i love
and marry them and i just couldn't
imagine living that for you if you
couldn't do that could you live that way
right but people still live that way
that's [ __ ] up so i think it's good
that that part is good oh you mean that
there was representation that it was
that take it out
it was normalized yeah yeah yeah to me i
think it's normal right it's normalized
isn't it you get an award now right
exactly right it's right we're over
normalized but
that's the point so but that's good good
good all good i think it's all good yeah
what's not good
is then you have this other side of like
transgender and all these other things
that and people are still entire that's
what you want great bravo live the life
you want but we started to talk about
very very small minute percentages and
now you're asking the world to sing to a
different tune so what happened was this
sort of pendulum swung into madness
some some was what starved was a
wonderful thing that needed to happen
has turned into some insane sort of like
almost like a dystopian future where up
is down
doubt is up right is wrong and wrong is
right and it's like you're seeing things
like leah thomas is a perfect symphony
you look at that and anyone if an alien
out of space flew in and said what the
[ __ ] are these people [ __ ] crazy
like what does putin think of that like
imagine what putin said well i think
china is pretty freaking out
like china like these things what's
wrong with the united states like are
they crazy well you know this thing
about how on tick tock in america it's
all of this gender stuff with these 15
year olds doing all the gender stuff but
they ban all of that in china and it's a
chinese company yeah you think that i
think they're trying to think
something's going on there you know who
used to kid around the decadent western
decay of of society well this is the
decay of of of of of normalcy i think
yeah and that's right i think it's very
much related to what happened with gay
people because because that was a good
thing that had to change and i think it
somehow swung into this bizarre or
alternate universe and i think we're
living that right now and you know you
know the really [ __ ] up part of that
as a gay person is that
when when all that happens then i see
people who start freaking out about gay
people and i'm like i actually somewhat
get it at some level not not at the
equality level where you have to treat
everyone equally but like the fear
because you see them with they want to
do this five-year-old kids they want
them to be able to talk to state
teachers and keep that private from the
parents
but you got do you admire the
we were talking about branding before in
messaging like with kovid that they got
everyone to say don't say gay even
though gay's not in the bill
like that somebody there is doing some
decent messaging well even if you hate
the message it's it's yes but it's
pretty easy when you have the entire
news
apparatus on your side and like again
they squash out alternative opinions uh
i give desantis a tremendous amount of
credit for always standing his ground um
and but i think though
like to me at least i never looked at
that as being serious i'm like this is
just nonsense it's just more idiotic
woke nonsense that and everyone knows
this everyone i'm assuming that you you
all know like you all know this is crazy
that the teach the four-year-olds or
first-graders apparently apparently the
disney employees don't know it yeah well
you know that's just like the most
virtue signaling [ __ ]
i've ever [ __ ] seen it's just
nonsense and you know how liberal i am
i'm [ __ ] liberal this is idiocy it's
just [ __ ] idiocy
we could use a little more like
old-school new york attitude huh it's
common have a common common sense common
sense right i don't know but i think you
know it's like
you wonder about the righteous wrath of
black people
and then i watch 12 years of slave and i
get it so it's like so it's it's always
more complicated that's why in some it's
almost like the analogy is like what
happened with gay people and this is
like the dystopian end of the gays like
where it's like now not about that
anymore it's almost with black people
like there needed to be i mean god when
you see things like that you can't even
believe it it's shocking now i'm from a
liberal family in in in queens like i
knew with no friends it was no one was
prejudiced yeah it wasn't like that
right isn't it crazy to think back on
that like there it wasn't at least where
we grew up new york
they were everybody was sort of there
yeah and nobody like there was i have no
recollection of anything like that so i
remember when i was young i was you know
in uh
first grade secretary was bussing
they started busting and there was some
riots i remember this very vaguely
but in my household
like there was never like the n-word
there was never anything it was always
like
quality you know like it was like she
was just a very liberal household i
didn't see any of that but i think
there's other
parts of of where i grew up in other
other parts of of queens where there was
a lot of animosity over blacks being
bussed in integrating schools it's a
very complex issue yeah and not to say
there was nothing there robert moses
purposely put the bridges on long island
low so the buses couldn't get through i
mean so it's not it's not like this is a
really [ __ ] up history yeah and that's
what i was almost saying with the with
the gay stuff that is like there was a
real problem they need to be solved but
then it goes into la la land because it
overcorrects itself is there a business
uh metaphor for that something like that
where like you accomplish your goals as
a business yeah
yeah if you sort of figure it you know
what i mean like the gays accomplish the
goal right of equality right you can you
can get married you can adopt kids you
can have kids right through surrogacy
all of that stuff they
the quality it's here but then you don't
stop there must be like a business
version yeah facebook
that you just keep going like whatever
the hell
they want
let me tell you what the mission was for
him to get really good there's a theory
i have on this too that organizations
tend to become exaggerations of what
their values are they exaggerate
themselves over time they're becoming
more and more and more extreme to what
their core values are they they become
like strat and became more crazy if it's
crazy a little crazy it's crazy crazy
crazy crazy yeah becomes more well it
always exaggerates because this echo
chamber and the sort of effect that
happens of self-reinforcement
surrounding yourself with like-minded
people the ultimate echo chamber is
facebook where they you know skew the
algorithms so you only see what you want
to see what you like to hear so your
you know your beliefs are reinforced
i've watched my one of my my uh my third
wife just become
you know you know going into the whole
you know the cute thing because they fed
her this stuff on on facebook you know
and i think it's really screwed up when
i look at facebook like this the values
of that company are just so [ __ ] up
and i don't think he'd probably start
off as a terrible guy
he wanted to get laid hey everybody want
to get laid right and then like you just
like it became this gross exaggeration
of almost like an
orwellian
sort of spoon feeding people what you
know they want to hear and what you want
them to hear at the same time are you
telling me you're not excited to go into
the metaverse led by humanoid robot mark
zuckerberg
the good thing about the metaverse is it
will not be led by mark zuckerberg it
will not be because by the nature of the
metaverse and everything about
blockchain it's a decentralizing force
so centralized institutions while
they'll play some role i i believe that
this next evolution is going to be away
from centralized institutions and we see
that right now happening in the
financial world with you have these new
platforms popping up like sushi swap and
pancakes off these just names of
decentralized exchanges that 15 guys
will do more volume a 15-man company
decentralized can outperform coinbase
that has 8 000 or 15 000 employees it's
so much more elegant and effective and i
i think that over time i don't think the
metabolism will be dominated by people
like zuckerberg i pray it's not
so you're pretty i know this obviously
but you're pretty bullish on on crypto
and and all that are you surprised that
bitcoin didn't move that much in the
last two months after what happened in
canada where they were freezing bank
accounts and you'd think that bitcoin
would have blown up and then all the
ukraine stuff and the swift system as
you mentioned before you'd think that
bitcoin right now or crypto in general
would all be skyrocketing but it's
actually not quite like that at the
moment so so the way crypto bitcoin
installed bitcoin
um it's still in its infancy
and until it matures and really becomes
more of a a currency in a legitimate
store of value whichever one you you
want to look at it as
it's gonna trade mostly like a growth
stock it's going to trade like a
speculative investment
and that means there's going to be times
where it's risk on and risk off right
now we're in a risk off environment
people are doing flights to safety
six months ago it was more risk on and
the hot money was going into things like
bitcoin and ethereum so that's part of
simply it was very much correlated with
the stock market as the stock market you
know stocks are going up bitcoin is
going up right
and also it's like is that partly just
because people have more money then and
they're just like i'll just put more
money into bitcoin too because i have
more money partially but what's
happening is when people are are scared
bitcoin is still not mature enough that
people look at it as a flight to safety
it's just not um
you know and that it was supposed to be
that and it probably will be that but
it's still not there yet and um and
bitcoin is still manipulated in other
words there's still some very big people
as [ __ ] with it right but i think
generally speaking right now i think
what you're seeing is that you've i
think it's healthy for bitcoins you have
this trading range
of like you know 35 whatever it is to
the high with 60. that's okay and i
think it it takes time like you know
when bitcoin crashed down to 3 000 or 2
000 it stayed there for him then
ultimately it has another rally so i
think it's building a base right now and
then ultimately it will go substantially
higher i think this pressure's
you know and again that's just my point
i tell you to buy because of that but
but but you know i think that
the nature of bitcoin the the scarcity
um
the stickiness that people tend to hold
for the long term
there's a lot of things that i think are
over the long term putting upward
pressure on the price what are you doing
with your money these days like what are
you in this like crazy time heavily into
into the crypto
defy
metaverse
um
very much into that and uh but i don't
have to invest my money so much it's not
what i do really my my my model is more
people will actually give me stakes in
their companies for for in exchange for
advice and and using my brand so i have
a very sort of a very much of a
risk-free model of getting involved in
companies now when companies that are
bigger and more all saying the better
deals
i'll put money in i don't mind doing
that but very often with speculative
deals they're looking for advice they're
looking for to get connections opened up
to them um
so i do a lot of that and they also
invest in in the off blockchain world as
well i have a great iced tea company
that um i'm involved which is blowing up
right now so you know for me you could
pimp them out you can come yeah well
there's nothing you can buy the product
you can buy the ic which is great it's
called my talk there you go unbelievable
that's amazing it's great it's all over
the place and in the northeast right now
they'll go nationwide this year you know
throughout the year um but you know
here's here's what here's what i believe
the safest best investment in the world
for anybody you want an investment tip
ready this buy the s p 500 in a van card
no load mutual fund
hold it reinvest the dividends and just
set it and forget it and that is your
best bet of all
so that does show me you're still
bullish on america to some degree right
well listen you know again i think that
america values
and it's global positioning and i said
the middle class is going to get
squeezed
but the 500 largest corporations
they're running this show anyway and
then they're behind those whole you know
you know military industrial complex i
mean they're in charge and what you're
doing is when you're buying that you're
buying the collective
ingenuity
of america and for all faults
the system is amazing what we have here
as an economic system
is powerful it rewards hard work it
rewards ingenuity um and unlike other
countries where success is frowned on
standing out is frowned on here we we we
worship or we emulate we elevate people
who have taken risks and make a lot of
money what would you do if you were ceo
one of these companies that was going
woke so if you were the head of disney
right now knowing everything i know
about you and now the company seems like
it's an upheaval and the board's angry
at you
and people are boy i mean it's hard to
gauge how much of it's real but if if
you had a general sense of what's going
on right now and they're coming to you
what would you do different than this
guy i mean to say that it was my job
yeah i i yeah because i i would simply i
would have what i would have done and i
would have never let it get this far
i would have been having this meh i
believe the problem
usually comes way before that it's like
this virus this cancer that's forming
and spreads and it spreads and it's
allowed to keep spreading and before you
know it the inmates are ruling the
asylum so i would have been you know
carefully or let's say almost daily
messaging you know things that were
against that whole thing supporting as
you know i feel about gay people
whatever but i would you know have a
very very different type of corporate
culture um but that said you know in the
way the world works right now it's
almost like you get cancelled like that
yeah so you know
it's pretty high and mighty me to say
i'll stick to my core beliefs but you
know i might have to be forced
specifically for fiduciary response or
i'd be fired as the ceo for not
pretending to be woke do you think
that's the move is that so many of these
companies probably even if they don't
fully get it are maybe not taking care
of their fiduciary responsibility
meaning they're not making the right
decisions for this for the company for
the yeah let me give you the the crux
system you just brought up a great point
okay
it's the ultimate diversion play
but whoa
we love the environment and we love gay
people and transgender and we're going
to [ __ ] destroy people in sweatshops
in indonesia and we're going to just
like literally there's such awfulness
nike i mean what they're doing i think
these companies are exploiting people
all over the world they're polluting
they're they're they're doing all this
terrible [ __ ]
raping and pillaging the village on a
[ __ ] daily basis pretty much all of
them you know without almost without
acceptance some less than others but
but they're woke
they're good corporate they're good
citizens of the world so the ultimate
thing for like apple to say like well
woke they're a bad guy in a disney movie
that's what i keep doing it's like
literally it's that it's that much of a
like
good people are more a little more and
they're just from destruction
destruction so they and their left is
amazing at that they just watch here
we're welcome
that means we can spill as much oil as
we want we can exploit as many people
from undeveloped countries as we want we
can just like literally avoid taxes and
keep money in different countries and
use clever transfer mechanisms so we
don't pay our fair share of taxes but
whoa we're good we're good but they'll
give you a shell fund and we love the
environment that says black lives matter
or something love the environment ah
it's gross and the guy and the black
lives matter guys like aren't they in
jail now
under indictment what happened to black
lives matter
it was like a scam yeah so like this
great cause like of course black lives
matter white lives matter yellow lives
matter lives matter right but these
people are just like freaking crooks
they they're in their environment aren't
they they're under indictment and the
and the the woman that was the head
bought three houses in malibu or
something i mean stop it did they send
oh she's got nothing on what's the name
on uh who's the one from the the uh the
uh
the senator from the west coast of
representative maxine oh maxine waters
who's got she's got like a 20 million
dollar house in hancock park while she's
running crenshaw or something i mean
these people isn't it it's you but
that's what i always tell people it's
like you got to admire the monster
yeah but by the way they don't even
touch [ __ ] argentina yeah at the
level of corruption there's a woman in
argentina this woman like christina or
something or other yeah who's like
literally like just she runs the whole
[ __ ] country oh [ __ ] the wealthiest
woman in the world she's like a putin of
argentina's woman and everyone loves her
and she's like he's only
raping pilgrims she's the [ __ ] you
know the kid syntha thank you christina
for the house roof overall and the food
not there you know
man oh yeah yeah hopefully this will air
after i get back from argentina i'll be
shopping yeah you could be in a lot of
trouble
no but it's amazing that like you see
this this weird
undercurrent
of politics it's almost like i i
hate to say this
because i don't really mean it but
there's at some point like i like just g
because at least you know what you're
getting you know it's completely
corrupted and there's no rights you
don't have no rights
okay get it that's the play i said on
the playing field it's almost like
better than like almost saying like you
they're pretending to be different right
well no no
i heard bill maher maybe a year ago say
something like that like they can get
[ __ ] done because they're not messing
around there's something admirable about
that
but and here i know people are going to
cut this exact part to make us look like
we're supporting china but
it comes at an obvious insane cost all
of the everything that we love about
life is the cost of them being able to
build a city real quick but not what
they love about life like i think
i think one thing i've learned from
traveling around the world so much
is that the world doesn't share our
values
many countries don't really care that
much about free speech
they like it they don't value it like we
do they didn't grow up with it's not
part of their core belief systems
people in russia love putin
i was there a few years back
everyone loves this guy they
said what is strongly we love a strong
leader we don't care oh we just want a
strong leader which is probably that's
what they want there all right now
they're probably having second thoughts
right now i'm guessing right it's a
little hard to tell don't you think like
you know we keep saying the meme is like
we've destroyed russia i don't believe
any of that yeah
i don't believe any of it by the way i'm
not saying that we haven't but i don't
believe any of it but why aren't we
seeing videos coming out of russia
i don't know riots in the streets
toppling the
the you know whatever
here's here's
the same analogy like i was out for
dinner with a ukrainian who hated putin
who was devastated over the invasion
he's like yeah we have nazis
it's like
it's like there's more to this whole
thing there's there's issues like you
know like ukraine was part of russia
like it's it's much more complicated
than the world's biggest i don't know
why it's like it's just listen again
i don't think it's i think it's a
terrible thing
and i think it's annoying to have to do
the caveats every time you're talking
about it it's really sad but you know um
but the bottom line is is that
this is not
enough to start world war three
and i resent when when someone like
zielinski is a u.s citizen says if you
don't save us if we don't we're gonna
it's world war three
what
i mean like what like i i don't know i
don't want world war three like so we
don't help you we don't give you more
guns and ammunition it's worldwide i
don't believe that for a [ __ ] second
just so you know i don't believe it for
a second i don't think there's any way
putin will ever go into a nato country
no no no way i don't think that's gonna
happen and by the way i think putin's
looking like a paper tiger a little bit
right now but i think also to give a
madman it seems like he's a madman right
i don't know maybe he's not but it seems
like he's acting that way
you need to give a madman an exit ramp
right like let's give the mad man okay
let's say especially one with nukes
right he's got 5 000 nuclear bombs let's
give the guy an exit ramp and like maybe
it's okay that he takes part of ukraine
and that becomes part of of russia and
people stop dying like why not like
think more pragmatically than
putin bed
ukraine good i i just don't believe that
for a [ __ ] split second jordan you'd
have to think for a minute i know
i know what what do you say the people
on cnn are going to be telling people
that they are allowed
even like the people on fox with the
exception of tucker yeah okay who
finally said what i was thinking i've
been thinking that the whole time let me
ask my you know my my wife i haven't
said it although she's like really i'm
like i said she's like it's so terrible
it is terrible it's awful but there's
more to this than they're saying
much more they're saying you know
and
here's another part of this whole thing
you know
when the whole world
gangs up on one thing that you have to
know it's like like it's just like it's
like the certainty everyone else has got
to tell you there's something wrong
isn't that the thing that's i think the
thing that's got my bell going off about
this i'm not saying i know exactly
what's right and i'm with you you can't
just invade a sovereign nation okay
nobody's defending putin but
to watch the swarm
basically every single person except
china and saudi arabia
there so is that really do you feel like
we're actually in in the midst of it i
mean biden said it just a couple days
ago new world order is on the way ah he
didn't say that during the election do
you remember him saying anything about a
new world order coming this
guy has done more damage
to the country it's amazing it's like
almost a talent and he doesn't you could
destroy something that quickly in just
two years
when trump you could hate trump
there's no way
this would have ever happened with trump
as president no
[ __ ] way trump is looking pretty
freaking good right no way that's what
happened yeah
no way just it's just and not because
putin was
thinks he's a man and this wouldn't have
happened
because you know there was just it was
just like this and by the way let me
just
put so he calls a war criminal well
that's helpful for
that's going to make the war stop
so now it's actually right so now so now
you give the guy no chance he can never
stop because if he loses he goes to the
head and gets hung at the hague so now
you create no possible peace solution
that's the that's the [ __ ] arms
manufacturers
moving biden's lips war war war death
that that money money money okay and
instability instability it's so [ __ ]
obvious like how could he say that it's
like i was i was so good what a [ __ ]
you know and they keep telling us we're
not going to world war three we're not
going to world war ii but we're going to
arm the guy we're going to talk about a
no-fly zone so then we'd have to shoot
down planes we're going to cut them off
the banking system like we're doing an
awful lot of [ __ ] i don't know where you
have to sign the dock he's begging for
no agreement
[ __ ] yeah i mean you want to you want to
destroy my country let's give me and
really i mean i understand you're in a
bad spot but like do you want to destroy
the world you want to take the whole
that's what will happen are you still
putting no flies in there that's it they
won't do it don't they won't happen
there's no there's no no fly though i
don't care what putin does they're not
it can't be that stupid
to go head-to-head with someone 5 000
nuclear bombs but we've got a lot of
wizards who got us into a lot of other
words that are telling us the no fly
zone will be just fine they're sure
they've never gotten anything right
before but you know the people some of
the generals they're saying
are just just people that are saying
because they want to go on tv they can't
possibly believe one i forgot who it was
saying yeah you could have this uh we
could have this um humanitarian flaws oh
yeah yeah that's a humanitarian corridor
that's what they call it that's gonna
work out really [ __ ] well you know
and and i also think that by the way i
just i yeah and you know i go on and on
about this i just i just think that that
arming ukraine is just
causing more lives to be lost right just
killing more ukrainians
belford finish me up with this
the world's nutty okay everyone gets it
we moved to florida life is good here
you're feeling good about life
um when i do my show my daily show every
day i'm always trying to tell people at
the end like i don't want you to get
crazy about politics i want you to do
something you're supposed to be doing
give the people the the jordan bell for
it like why everything's going to be
okay and why you got to just keep going
even even if you're worried that it's
not going to be okay oh no i think it's
everything's going to be okay so let's
see
what happens is even when like there's a
recession they say it's a three percent
contraction of the economy
what does that really mean
so if you if you made fifty thousand
dollars last year and then suddenly your
income goes to 48 500.
you're still paying your rent you're
cutting back a little bit but you're
still living like i i think like what
happens is people that are living
empowered lives people that are willing
to work hard and put one foot from the
other you're going to be okay
there's always a path forward to make
money to live a great life to be
empowered in this country in the united
states right
it just makes it a little bit harder
they just make it harder instead of
having a tailwind you have a little bit
of a headwind
but that's it you just pedal a little
bit faster listen when i got out of jail
i was saddled with a very large fine
and by law
the maximum they could make me pay is 25
of my income you know what i said to
myself when i got out of jail i said i'm
not going to try to evade this fine
i'm just going to make so much [ __ ]
money
that the 25 won't even be pimple on my
ass and that was my attitude i'll make
so much money i'll just pay that
win-win for everybody how quick did you
knock it out well no i still pay but oh
you're still there there's no one
getting no there's no more investors
left yeah investors doesn't want to rest
the best hasn't gotten money for 10
years it's just like this another two
years i gotta pay this is some it's
ridiculous okay but the point i never
tried to look at that as i mean well
then i'll just either stop working or
i'll try not to pay no i'll just work
even harder so if the world gets a bit
tougher if politicians like biden create
a playing field that's just sort of
tilted against you just pet a little bit
faster
it's worth it because you know what you
know we live once right and
where you are in your life right you
can't control what happens randomly but
you are the master you're running your
ship you're the master of your own
destiny you have the ability i don't
care who you are as long as you're
healthy you're breathing
you can improve your lot in life if you
want every human has the ability to get
ahead in this country if you're someone
else i can't some country it's difficult
but even there you can always get ahead
and i think that all of this stuff is
noise it's disturbing you can worry
about it yes you can worry about it but
to think
for a second that it will stop you from
living an empowered life
that's a story that you tell yourself as
an excuse
because you're not willing to do what it
takes
to get what you want in life and i i
firmly believe that that it's that it's
a story that you tell yourself that oh
it's the government it's the economy
it's my parents it's the news
it's all story and once you stop with
that story and and learn what you have
to learn go out there and do what you
got to do you can get ahead in this
world
so do we uh start a company now do we
drink tequila i think we drink tequila
jordan bell for ladies and gentlemen
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our lifestyle playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell